je suis juni en fait je cherche de
nouveau dossier
il est avec moi
[Musique]
c'est pas moi personnellement mais c'est
le cabinet
[Musique]
je te trouve très courageuse
je suis désolé de l'avoir inquiété pour
rien mais vous savez j'en vois tellement
que
ah ouais mais c'est dommage parce que
c'est grâce à ça que tu as une promotion
tes parents ils savent parce que tu es
un cancer d'aujourd'hui
il y a des gens qui sont malades je sais
pas si tu comprends ce mot malade en
valeur Oui je pense qu'il comprend parce
qu'il vient juste de député une
chimiothérapie n'est-ce pas
donc tu as loué un cancéreux pour nous
faire de la peine Kiloutou la main
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ton cul ta façon de
parler là tu peux pas faire un petit
efforts
[Musique]
il va falloir que
c'est très gentil toi merci
[Musique]